we here at CBS News are grieving after  the loss of two of our colleagues Chris  rain was an editor in our London bureau  since the 1980s he died at the age of 62  after a long fight with cancer and Chris  Myers was the deputy chief of our Los  Angeles Bureau a veteran journalist  Chris enjoyed working with students was  a Bears fan wanted to teach the next  generation how to be responsible  journalists and his giving continues  eight lives have been saved as a result  of Chris's decision to be an organ donor  and we talk a lot here about how we are  family we all spend so much time  together and it really isn't it's times  like these where our hearts go out to  each other  Chris Chris was such a like Chris Myers  every time he walked into the bureau he  was there with a big smile a great  journalist we were all still coming to  chat with us it was sudden very some  life is beautiful